hey everybody welcome back to the
channel I'm here with Brandon acre we
reached out to see if anyone had at the
or bow in Chicago and there is an expert
for us here so I'll probably start with
the unboxing footage it doesn't look
that different like there could be a
bass guitar in this are you open so oh
oh of course so that's why we have the
neck extension holy SH the coolest part
about when it's folded up these long
strings here they're folded around this
cylinder yeah and they there's the rap
tension still so they're in tune so you
just yeah so now you just unfold the
neck take this pin out put it here so
can't collapse on me Wow now so that's
the full instrument yeah is that is that
even a shot so we need to go even wider
it's really hard to get this thing in
frame
[Music]
it's beautiful yeah what is this thing
pure bow in English Theora bah or a
katana in Italian it's an Italian
invention invented around 1580 and
basically it's a member of the loot
family yeah so you know in Renaissance
the loot was kind of the guitar of its
day the bowl shaped instrument with the
same kind of shape it's smaller you see
it in paintings all the time yeah is
that what makes it a lute rather than
the guitars the the bowl shape on the
back that's one of the features that you
can use to determine oh that's so a
looked or look like instrument the lute
family is is vast because the lute had a
whole family of a little lute to big
lute if you think like violin viola
cello bass this is the base lute of the
family this part from here to here and
then so that was in the Renaissance and
the Baroque period comes around around
1600 this group in Florence got to get
together called the Florentine Camerata
and they said we want to invent this new
style of music novo music a this new
music and it was gonna be opera and we
need the perfect instrument to accompany
the voice and this is what they came up
with basically what we have is a lute on
this half and then they graft on this
giant neck extension to add seven or
eight more strings and now we can not
only play in this register but also
[Music]
add that low contrabass what are we
gonna hear this is an H string - the
bass right so we have 8 pegs here
basically a base lute and so that's what
this is if I basically just fret this
happen how low does it go how's it tuned
so basically it's like actually like a
guitar yes half and then down the octave
E hey okay then we get to the long
portion which is jeans that's a G below
drop D okay so it's contrabass yeah is
this a situation where there isn't a
standard tuning for these normally this
reason I would say is up to the up to
the play on here play it depends on what
you're doing if you're playing in an
orchestra or for opera then you decide
what's the most useful notes that mm-hmm
I don't know if you're familiar with the
string material for for lutes but they
know they they use gut normally there's
actually sheep gut yeah so sheep
intestine and so that's what the strings
are made of are these actual gut strings
so the frets are actual guts and then
the rest of them are our guts and nylon
mixed together they're kind of synthetic
guns yeah if you see here actually on my
tenon strings
they're wound and that's not historical
these are wound because if you have a
gut string at this pitch it sounds a bit
more tubby but you need the length to
give it to clarify the pitch to give it
the punch but because of the windings it
also has a good punch to it but if you
notice
[Music]
it sounds a little bit different to that
fellow basis because it's so long I have
this really nice punchy bass range and
then I have this really delicate
upper register yeah my thumb is used to
play all of the contrabass notes the
diet paesan's we call them and then my
left hand only frets the actual first
seven strings how far does this go up
like does that go up to an octave I have
an octave yeah on top so it's there so I
can do so that's still very that yeah so
you don't need really more than 12 frets
because this is a bass instrument they
don't want it to go very high in the
first place in fact just when the
instrument is getting higher
there's the highest note it goes down
the octave and the reason for that is
because when they were making this
instrument bigger and bigger and bigger
they found out that the the thin gut
strings that you need to get those
pitches an octave higher kept breaking
so they just tuned them down the octave
yeah
but ended up working out in a really
beautiful way because then you have this
really mid contrabass range instruments
as a player you have to adjust what
you're used to because you know on a
guitar we used to kind of thinking you
roll the chord and it goes put over them
and strums low to high but on this one
to go low to high I have to do this
weird arpeggio where I go
at the end so there's a whole piece by
cats burger from 1604 where you use that
arpeggio
[Music]
and then what I have here as well as my
F which is here is stopped and the short
neck but I have an option to make it a
long one and put it oh that's the other
one but F is the the first note that if
you're gonna change keys
you're gonna want an f-sharp first right
it's the first accidental so now I can
change it here without getting up I
might hear about the F was up there and
then sobs don't play concerts and I'd
have to get up and everybody you need
you need another assistant yeah but so
this is so cool cuz I finally have my F
and I can just raise it to F sharp and
keep playing also this this folding
thing that's not normal it's definitely
a historical these just need an enormous
case before this and I have yet on the
train as hell flying is the worst and
you don't have any fine tuners on the
other side it's exactly the friction
pegs that have never worked for me on
any you have to get really well fitted
pegs if the pegs are well fitted they're
great one of the coolest things about
this instrument the frets because
they're made of intestine just like the
strings were I tie them on myself yeah
and that means I can also move them so I
can slant them the tune just like a
sitar yeah is that really I didn't know
that do you find a use for that or to
you absolutely we live in the land of
equal temperament and that's what we
actually grow up hearing everything on
the radio is an equal temperament but
the weird thing is equal temperament is
out of tune yeah so all of these
instruments that have threats that are
seven equal temperament are they're
compromised so that they're actually
equally out of tune each note yeah come
to accept that as being right because
you can play in every key and it sounds
good
what they did with these old instruments
because you can tie on the frets as they
played in temperaments and what that
means is you can defy the octave
differently than twelve even notes and
you can favor certain chords by playing
this normal G major chord and
equal-tempered third
it sounds okay yeah but the third is
sharp so I can take this note here for
example if I'm playing a piece in G
major and I want that really nice B I
can just slant the fret down and now
I mean that sounds like a fourth
beautiful it's perfectly in tune that
was something that when I first started
recording with guitar just drove me
crazy and I didn't realize that there's
compromises on the fretboard so I would
be strumming especially a D chord I hate
the D chord yeah it's even not exactly
equal temperament so part of its sound
is that it's kind of attitude what you
do is you sort of you figure out I'm
playing for example a suite that's in
the key of G major so I'm going to tune
this low note to f-sharp and then I'm
gonna get my frets or we arranged that G
major sounds fantastic but a G sharp
major chord would sound awful and that
way I'm gonna sound so in tune so you
want to play this yes I do
[Laughter]
hey everybody so well I'm trying to
figure out how to hold this instrument I
want to say thanks to our sponsor honey
honey is a free browser extension that
automatically scans the internet for
coupons and discounts and then applies
it to your cart at checkout so there's
no extra steps
it's just saving you money as you shop
normally so for my case even if we just
need a new hard drive to put this video
footage on it'll just automatically add
a discount from somewhere and ends up
saving a lot of money particularly for
this video because the new fee or bow is
$13,000 and then 10% if I didn't I just
rented it you can install honey by going
to join honey calm slash Scallon takes
about two clicks to install and works
with practically everything you'd be
buying online probably not at the oar
boat but everything else so there's
really no reason not to use honey it's
free to use it's easy to install within
two clicks so shop with confidence get
honey for free a join honey calm slash
Scallon that's join honey calm slash
Scanlon honey
the smart shopping assistant that saves
you time and money when you're shopping
online alright let's get back to fewer
Bowen so there you are looking down at
this is really intimidating you forget
everything you know right yeah there is
a guitar tuning buried in these strings
here you gotta find it so
this is a C and dismissal from there
that'd be your anchor and then you can
make a c-major okay there we are off
beautiful Wow
as soon as I take my hand off them
oh wow this is really confusing yeah so
if this is AG yeah okay okay
Ling is the topic where's the a here's
your lo a you're gonna play like this
with a restroom I'll be your face yeah
yeah you got the base okay one two three
four
[Music]
[Music]
that was brave to venture in I figured
you know yeah you got like seven out of
12 chance a bit than a note and key so I
figure I just go for it I'm super I'm so
turned around I'm not being
[Music]
jeez it's like I go to all right here's
the cuz normally yeah normally it's like
I go further than I need to and then go
down but here I go further than I need
to I think I need to and I'm nowhere
near and like even earlier I needed to
mute the strings and I'm used to you
know even on an H string or a nine
string I could go but you're supposed to
play with like the fingers down with
your pinky down and because you're
picking off there's no key that gives
you reference to know how far the basis
rings yeah look at your right hand hold
on yeah so you have to memorize where
the pitches are and there's a distance
between your pinky and the phone yeah
yeah that's really hard I mean if I put
my pinkie down enough to where I know
it's not gonna be muting the string I
mean it's that much it's huge
yeah it's enormous people like me to
play his instruments our specialty is to
try to play this instruments like they
were yeah to get as close to the
Storyful authenticity as possible so we
read these old treatises and assembly
century and these paintings are saying
okay where they trying to get at and our
job is to figure out how to make make
the sound sound as close as possible
never doing
yeah this one second okay
I'm having a lot of trouble wrapping my
head around this it'll take a bit of
yeah
[Music]
you just went forward god that was just
a gamble okay I'm gonna try this one
again
[Music]
it's a really beautiful instrument it's
it's a lot to wrap your head head around
she takes one comment if you like I was
thinking I brought another instruments
yeah yeah we should C minor G minor C C
D minor hey okay I'm gonna play it slow
[Music]
it's so just having one yeah just having
my entire life being a Secord I looked
at a high E and then I find the C and go
from there and just having it one string
off okay I'm gonna get it though
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean it you just learned how to play a
seventeenth-century
tell Babu is essentially a cool and that
right there there's a thousand pieces
based on that I also love when you're
playing an instrument like this with so
many strings that are there to freely
vibrate as you get all these great
sounds out of you'll hit a note and then
you get the other piece of it yeah so if
you just think of these two i mean ii na
right yeah
[Music]
it was sounding really good yeah I think
you're officially the third best year of
a flange punch do you want to try to
play this thing yeah yeah this is this
is more my speed when you have the this
range to just to have this ability to
have a low note
[Music]
this hand is kind of like a left hand of
the piano and this is kind of the right
I've been playing mostly minor stuff but
in G major there's tons of things you
can do like
[Music]
if you want a high note you have to go
way up here but then it sounds great
with the juxtaposition
[Music]
you know that register the difference
between that contrabass range to the
treble is is huge so yeah it just has
this you know powerful deep warm sound
I'm sure I could do this for another
four hours so we do need to end the
video so you can subscribe if you like
I'm sure this in the last time we do
something like this in this channel also
brandon has a channel if you'd like to
check it out it's a bit of a risk after
the prep way